by law I am writing right and I am
cheering and I'm Michelle cute welcome
two reasons to see where we give your
reasons to six and maybe not to see
despicable me 2 so what's chillin out
broseph reason to see number one the
minions I love these little I love these
guys yeah bad the cute adorable do like
the same things over and over again but
they're so [ __ ] funny for some reason
I love um how they always have them
impersonating um a famous song they're
just so freaking adorable and I love
them I want one they are don't and the
thing is like I don't know I'm talking
to people outside what most people seem
annoyed by the minions of the one I see
the trailer I'm like kind of annoyed by
the minions but when i watch the movie I
was like these guys are really cute and
funny yeah verizon I've never been night
by the minions there's something about
him that seems a little gimmicky and so
made for children you know that's you up
no like I can't get enough of them but i
think i just needed them in context of
the movie instead of having them rammed
down my throat by advertising you need
to see them interact with humans to a
lot of the time they were to you know
get the get the jokes across another so
yeah the minions they [ __ ] rock there
isn'ta see number two good rule / steve
carell i love grill I'm gonna say this
about so many characters in this review
just warning you ahead but i think that
grew is such a lovable character because
he's so serious yet he's so warm-hearted
under
this you know serious facade you just
feel so much for him and he's really
relatable and i think steve carell does
an amazing job I give steve carell lots
of props for bringing life to groove
yeah you could tell he gets lost in the
voice like Andy imagine a guy who's not
just doing a voice in the booth you you
imagined a guy a whole news in his whole
body language and everything like that
you never think once you're hearing
Steve Carell you're so caught up in life
and in the character and the voice is so
unique it's perfect he's got really good
timing and really good presents about
his voice generally yeah and you know
it's helped by the animation obviously
but you know a good voiceover job you
know really brings things life and i
think steve carell definitely does that
cruise a lot of fun I don't like this
pickable me two more than the first one
but I actually enjoyed grew more in this
one so yeah Steve Carell grew rocket
rock'n'roll I would totally suck no I
suck GRU stick Despicable Me reason is
see number three the directing and
writing okay I'm gonna be honest when I
first heard of the plot to the spec for
me too I was wondering please dear God
make them pull this off because i feel
like this is a really weak plot that is
a wish not a wonder you know what was
wondering if you're wondering your it's
a question you sounded like a [ __ ]
idiot basically what i'm trying to say
is that they were able to pull off this
storyline really well and i think i had
a lot to do with the writing and the
directing yes Davis somebody did right
yeah or in order for the story to be
well that has to do with the writing and
the directing no one's things that you
know I think it usually it's sound is on
time I get a lot of problems to the
director and the hear that she would
give a prop to the director I don't need
the props for this movie it's all
digital animation yeah why was the guy a
prop
yeah mad kudos to the director and the
writer or writers of this directors
actually two it's too dude yeah I was
just I was really impressed the
directing on this movie there's actually
some like cool shots in this film
there's look at the things that have
like the action sequences are done well
and they're really exciting and badass
at the same time but then most of this
movie has a lot of you know fun and I
like it because this is a comedy and a
lot of times these animated movies have
humor in them but they're not
necessarily comedy to get cool action
for the thrills you get those minions
you like make you just crack up and they
they may use they took advantage of them
even more in this one and they actually
made them essentials of the plot I won't
complain oh I was really impressed with
how they made everything come together
there's a lot of impressive things about
this movie actually I like it more than
I thought I did we get a lot of animated
movies and especially lately except for
maybe some of the more recent ones you
know it's like Pixar movies this kind of
gold standard or was those got you know
20 story three is a pretty serious movie
and so is up and things like that and it
was nice to have despicable me around
cuz it was like oh yeah here's something
that is actually a cartoon again and is
something that's you know it's got that
sort of wacky cartoony slap stickiness
about it yeah it's wacky besides it's
not annoying though yeah it's not it's
not like what DreamWorks used to do
where it was like hey pop culture like
it has that sort of spy movie kind of
yeah kind of fun and thrilling an
intrigue and it's a good time and yeah
and like there when there's drama there
the drama actually works like any good
comedy you need a little bit of drama
nor for the funniness to be effective
lesson number one people your take
despicable me 2 has not very different
but quite a different plot from the
first movie in a whole plot theme of a
second one basically is that ok he's now
changing to like the good side right so
he's going to do good evil and I think
that that switch like that can be
difficult to pull off still has heart
still relatable still an enjoyable film
nothing that you feel is super like oh
they just put this into Phillip to fill
in the script yeah you realize like how
you can make I could even see a third
one about this because you're making a
good point in you know like grew is not
just a rehash of what we saw it last
time it's not like every [ __ ] Pirates
of the Caribbean movie with Jack Sparrow
but you know what I mean no this is a
different grew that we're getting this
time like we're seeing like who we
changed into because in the first one he
had to learn how to you know love
himself now he has to learn how to love
someone else yeah well and then part of
what school too is like they flipped the
format because in the first one it's
sort of a game of tops it's like two
guys trying to outdo each other and this
one is more of a whodunit kind of story
some people are saying it doesn't feel
as fresh as the first one I thought for
a sequel it felt pretty fresh so yeah
the directing and writing rocks your
[ __ ] reason to see number for the
[ __ ] animation you know pigs are is
known for being that gold standard of
animation a lot move out of the way
Pixar I'm not saying that what I'm
saying is it okay there's been many
people who tried to be Pixar and they
fail I think the animation and this
movie is fantabulous for it not being
Pixar it's not good picsart but it's
pretty freaking close it's like Pixar's
here it's like right here knocking on
Pixar's ass you see knocking on Pixar's
ass yes what does that even mean hello
knocks on someone's at some really weird
light porno haha excuse me are you
enjoying knocking yeah no I I quite
enjoy the innovation in this movie too
as far as animated movies go it's al
it's you know they have a very
exaggerated cartoon lifestyle it feels
like a cartoon yeah it's weird it looks
really well put together and really real
for what it is you know and if
everything's very vibrant and bright and
candy colored and it's very vibrant to
look at I really enjoyed the animation
in this movie and their design of
everything there was some really cool
attention to detail that I noticed like
Gru's I've had like a glisten like real
eyes and that that's like detailed stuff
that Pixar with you that many other
animation studios kind of fail to do
they also drew Mexicans very well
there's a lot of Mexicans what Mexicans
the bad guy why can't they be the good
guy well the first time it was like Bill
Gates was the bank he was not Bill Gates
you look just like dunking well whatever
it Bill Gates is white I know my god
point is is that if you're pissed off
about a Mexican guy being a bad guy
imagine how white people feel man why
people must watch almost any movie and
go why is the bad guy white guy I don't
like I kind of retro actively sucks cuz
I white guy is like the shittiest
pedigree to have because you're
responsible for like three quarters of
all evil that's been to reason is a
number five supporting characters yeah
the supporting cast in this movie is
fantastic I heard Al Pacino it was
replaced by Benjamin Bratt because Al
Pacino had creative differences but he's
willing to do movies like Righteous Kill
and eighty eight minutes haha and Jack
and challenge oh yeah Jackie jail yeah
but no despicable me 2 i've got some
issues with plus you know i mean kids
love Benjamin yeah you know much better
choice so I'll bachina was gonna be el
macho what was this issue with the old
bunch of character tease to Mexican I
don't like it what was wrong with going
in the voice-over booth out Miceli like
it couldn't have been this could not
have ended up that better like really al
pacino's most grave acting career choice
[ __ ] sure see should have been
despicable me talk but you better be
right he doesn't get job yeah I didn't
did I sound like that yeah
I saw his name of the credits don't like
him who does he guess he must be a
watcher like Kristen Wiig's in this
movie yeah she's really good i will I
think she's a great addition she plays
grooves love interest and she's up she's
fun characters hey you know normally
suck what characters like that would you
they just making some tough hot secret
agent babe no they made her like wacky
and over the top but still good at what
she does you know really what she is in
this movie is like the excitable rookie
who knows all the gases and stuff and
who's just really excited to be working
with you so you know and that's a fun
dynamic to watch play out the other
characters had really good chemistry
together and you know they bounce off
each other and the romance it made sense
and the kids were great too i still love
the kids you know they obviously don't
focus on them as much but there's still
integra yeah they're integral to the
story Oh Agnes the you feel like I'm
Agnes yeah you kind of look like Agnes
hey good if I Gagne's mm-hmm now I look
like something it was like sad Michelle
I even enjoyed a little bit of you know
seeing him as a father would like oh my
little girls dating all right you know
don't know Mexicans and the designs of
the characters too cuz they do like I
said you know they get into some more
you know you get some different feeling
types and there are some cool things
they get into theirs I liked how they
kind of put a little like secret agent
spin on it kind of remind me is like
look like I guess Tom Cruise and
animation and fatter at some points that
movie language of oz believe me what the
[ __ ] did I said no no no I mean we said
leatrice do you mean like in mission
didn't I say mission impossible no said
like Tom you said like Tom Cruise but
fatter you should fill in for me for
straight to the point I think it does me
Helen are you sure really thick you
could do and grow he's like a fat Tommy
fat Romanian how do cruise you know how
to add a cruise legs support
he has a very large bulbous viotti but
his legs are lights thanked 26 that are
combined and like his head just kind of
grows out of his shoes they should do a
dark realistic with humans
interpretation of despicable me yeah it
was like really accurate makeup yeah a
bunch of [ __ ] like Daniel day-lewis
the playgroup Ryan's consensus a good
time with your family is the reason to
see despicable me 2 a good time with
your families the reason to see
despicable me 2 yeah it's a good time
there's everything for the family is in
this movie and uh yeah it's really if
you're not into family movies I wouldn't
advise this movie Jerry's consensus good
cartoon fun is the reason to see
despicable me 2 good cartoon fun is the
reason to see despicable me 2 ya know
this movie's a good time you know it's
like you said it's a lot of fun for the
family and you know it's not only for
the little kids so mom and dad are gonna
have fun too I hope Michelle's consensus
despicable me 2 is the reason why
animated movies are made despicable me 2
is the reason why animated movies are
made now you might be thinking why
didn't I say that for monsters ain't
monsters University um I really like
monsters University don't get me wrong
but I think Despicable Me actually likes
better you're really throwing down with
Pixar today No alright guys thanks for
checking out our review for despicable
me part 2 why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below and tell us what
did you think of the [ __ ] movie does
it compare to the first one better I
don't know I come up with these
questions on the spot every time and
that is the best I got for today and
once you're done telling us that
information once you come over on here
to this uh this link and click it and
you'll see more episodes of reasons to
see and once you're done you know
clicking on that link and watching all
of our episodes yeah you can you have a
start the first one and then work your
way up to 46 or without back in the day
when we have music yet grooming
moving yeah take on those are old bass
reviews yeah but really change along
yeah we've grown man yeah definitely we
couldn't even could even get this [ __ ]
proper yeah anyway once you're done with
that you can click on this link to like
us on Facebook and you could click on
this link to like us on Twitter will not
like us but tweet us on Twitter yeah all
around and the last but certainly not
least if you want to get updated every
time a new review or a video is out
subscribe click on Michelle clicker hi
you know what would be weird if two
people you know switch their hearts and
then so that way they could say you have
my heart deck a be an interesting movie
that would be the most extreme gesture
of love but then you would have to make
damn [ __ ] sure that you're nothing
happens to your relationship ever you
guys have to basically stay in
cryostasis so that you never change so
that you never nothing comes between you
because then what it's like be like a
good legend like an old school movie
then it's like they switch each other
stars do anything it takes place after
they know they're already like two
separate warriors on a distant sides of
the planet it's like they can't find
love they're loners because their heart
belongs to another yeah oh I just did it
James Franco's next masterpiece well hey
i love them interesting how's old
interests that was pondering and your
highness you know he's really good at
the old school day movies don't get
lambda lost and I'm he wasn't in that
one but you know what kind of
in there with your highness why I mean
that's a like a will ferrell oblivious
guy naming round movie yeah your
highness is like a pothead oblivious guy
saying off landish things it made evil
jokes yeah there's just not die hard
[ __ ] in their loss what is your point I
don't understand how you're defending
yourself right that old olden times
movie that's shitty there's a comedy
that involves that same group of people
are you comparing a movie that's about
prehistoric animals to the medieval
times right now several comedies though
you